you were watching ColdFusion TV hi
welcome to another ColdFusion video so I
just wanted to follow up in the last
video that I did and also give you a few
comments for where I was coming from
with it firstly I want to thank all of
the e for your positive comments and
also the critiques and a really
appreciate your honest feedback
everything in the last video that I said
wasn't deed factual but I think what a
few people had a problem with was my
time I was very negative about the whole
concept of central banks but really I
was just frustrated what they've been
doing and the unfairness of today's
system and a lot of people are it is
hard to fit multiple angles in while
trying to lay out an entire economic
system in 20 minutes I do want to
clarify that not every central bank in
the world is equally terrible and they
do have some good attributes such as
being the lender of last resort this is
something that I cut out of the video
due to time but what the lender of last
resort means is that when commercial
banks in the country are in crisis the
central bank can step in and bail them
out this is so that innocent depositors
don't lose their money so that's one
good aspect but the way that our system
is chained to debt the way the Federal
Reserve was established and the way it
bailed out the very worst banks allowing
them to commit more crimes in the
derivative market and the way that it's
affected all over their economies is
something that just doesn't sit well
with me also a lot of what I said came
from a deeper place it wasn't just
reading a few articles in the subject I
like to listen to and read up on experts
that at least predicted the Oh a crisis
and ideally have had experience with
consulting monetary bodies I try to get
as many viewpoints as possible what I
didn't have time to mention in the
previous video is that according to
analysts that have actually sat down and
talked with members of central bank's
the models that they're using are wrong
professor Steve King head of the school
of economics Kingston University from
over a century ago they're convinced
ourselves you could leave money out with
your model of the macro economy and a
lot of model the macro economy properly
so they do have models without money
without banks for that debt they're
derived from assumptions about the real
data driving the financials answers
they're not the nitrus inputs there and
of course there's presumptions they're
wildly wrong so any of that's the state
of the model
and if you lift out the financial system
you couldn't see a financial crisis
coming for obvious reasons this is the
major reason that was so wrong and so
long as banks and credit and private
debt we're all going in the same
direction so they were rising if you fit
major model v the data that was being
generated by the economy like tweaking
its parameters sufficiently it could
look like actually doing accurate
prediction everything totally changes of
course when the direction of debt goes
in the opposite opposite ways professor
Kane tried to tell this to the Reserve
Bank of Australia but they wouldn't
listen he then went to warn the Bank of
England and surprisingly they were open
to his new ideas and asked him to come
back two more times time to really
understand how the economy works but the
fat and the people within it don't seem
to be nowhere near I think the best Bank
on that front and this is going to be an
intriguing experience for them for the
next five years is the Bank of England
well it's hard to answer that question I
think a couple of reasons
individuals I think there's some people
inside the Bank of England I won't
mention names but good people who have
been skeptical about the crisis going
through the crisis of thinking we didn't
see their coming this got to be
something wrong with our models we
didn't see this coming and secondly the
bank has now developed a new research
package they're calling one one Bank
where they're trying to take guidance
from all sorts of approaches to
analyzing a complex system not just what
economic theory tells us to do other
experts in the financial field such as
Jim Rickards and Bayern Armstrong have
worked at the US government on occasion
and have both noted that the central
banks weren't using the correct models
of course there's grains of salt with
all of this but at least they're
significant data points a lot of the
actions of the central banks are taking
now may hurt us in the long run for
example where I live in Australia our
central bank is repeating what Alan
Greenspan did in 2001 2007 in addition
to this our commercial banks are also
giving out subprime mortgages according
to a number of whistleblowers with a
large number of Australian banks or all
Australian banks were manipulating loan
documentation in order to get loans
across the line that for their lending
standards the kind of loans that
they're learning sounds were designed to
stop an unknown number of people where
were being foreclosed on despite the
fact that they should never have gotten
the loan they did and it was induced by
document fraud what amount starting the
fraud so the similarity to the two the
US subprime crisis are very obvious a
lot of experts warn that this could
cause another housing bubble so what I'm
trying to say is that I just don't enjoy
seeing the same crisis play out time and
time again I hate seeing people get hurt
this isn't to mention that ultra low
interest rates also hurt savers and
pensioners too for many it's frustrating
to see entities being able to distort
our economies so I thought I'd at least
educate people and how the system works
and discuss some solutions that are
talked about by experts in various
fields these solutions are coming in
future videos but in retrospect it
wasn't the greatest move on my part to
leave you hanging with all that
information and no solution but I'm
letting you know that I'm talking with
some blockchain experts Bitcoin
researchers and some financial
researchers to bring you some solutions
that are at least being talked about
just a heads up this is all going to
take some time to get organized so hang
tight there will be some other videos in
the meantime so anyway this was just a
video letting you know where I was
coming from in regards to the last video
I made thanks for watching and I'll see
you again soon for the next video cheers
guys have a good one
cold fusion
[Music]